[Music]
guys it is with uh great despair
that i must announce i don't know that
cnn plus
is no longer going to be continued oh no
where am i gonna get my news now
only weeks after they're released cnn
plus
is no longer who the [ __ ] was gonna buy
that judging by bart's face that's the
most average reaction of everybody what
the hell is that i know i'm like what
the [ __ ] is the difference between
nobody ever was interested nobody ever
knew no one asked for it no one wanted
it
that's why was it like the behind the
scenes of the [ __ ] news channel the
extra content what other pluses are
there's espn to us it was just a bunch
of like original like they had some
original content you buy santa and
pay-per-views i don't even think that
was yeah it's like sanjay gupta vlogs or
something hey guys what's up
more cnn stuff it's just stuff that you
don't like and then uh i mean what was
on there like there was like a jessie
smelly documentary on there for real i
think yeah but i don't know if you guys
finished not wanting but from his side
but he's innocent
they should have if i did it but him
yeah i should have done like in in
detail like astrology or something like
if you pay for this you'll have very
accurate astrology yeah i mean that
would have got it plus yeah that's like
flush i really need to know my future
the crazy thing is even as i'm like
reading it and trying to um like i
looked at the list of stuff they were
offering like what was it i was falling
asleep even reading
[Laughter]
i was just like i don't know what any of
this [ __ ] who's running cnn right now
because i feel like out of all the
alphabet agencies um the the news
agencies
cnn is getting it the worst with
everyone's like you guys are the most
fakest [ __ ] pieces of shits and the
main thing is because they claim to be
nonpartisan right originally well what
are they leaning i think their biggest
is when they went after joe rogan
and they [ __ ] lost that battle i
think that's when that was bad and they
put the halloween filter on him yeah
yeah common man of uh that people that
watched joe rogan a lot yeah you're
gonna [ __ ] lose come on dude they
they took up the biggest l are they the
ones that said he ate horse yeah horse
medicine and then they they took his
video and they distorted it made them
look like sickly and green
but yeah that's a huge massive loss
because they did invest a shitload of
money i don't i don't think
i feel like the number is like they're
just trying to keep it under wraps but
yeah they uh
a whole lot of people were you know that
and a lot of people are losing your job
see which sucks but they're getting like
six months severance for
them failing this so it's not bad it's
pretty that's pretty freaking good
budget geez
like we effed up everybody on the team
gets six months well i guess because the
worst thing that could happen after this
is people complaining and then there's a
documentary about everyone getting
[ __ ] over because of this so it's like
that
yeah because if you give them severance
and you know you don't have to give
severance right you know it's not the
thing you have to do but if you do offer
it you can put a little claws don't talk
about this don't say [ __ ] because i gave
it to you right that's the freaking
people's worst nightmare now it's just a
documentary about whatever happened
see what they do firefest yeah they're
doing freaking uh
there's like they might do like an
america's next top model one because
apparently like i'd watch that when you
look back they were like treated really
badly like all the models oh wow like
anything that ever existed pre like woke
era is now like under scrutiny for life
remember that show the swan do you guys
remember that no it's that the swan was
a show on like fox 11 it was around the
time like american idol was popular and
they would just give you plastic surgery
like they would get like they would
market it as you get like a really ugly
person and they look at themselves in
the mirror and they'd be like crying
they talk about like what they hate
about themselves and then they do a
makeover and then the end of the episode
they don't let them look at themselves
at all during this process and then they
make them look in the mirror for the
first time and they start crying and
they they do this whole thing but it's
all plastic surgery yeah and it was
called the swan
is that bad or is that good well like a
good damn bad now yeah like you do that
[ __ ] today no way
because because today they would say the
person the reason why that person
doesn't like themselves is because of us
socially it's like society has created
an image of beauty that they don't meet
i didn't need a magazine to tell me
somebody's ugly
seven ways to tell if you're ugly all
right
like i knew as a [ __ ] child bro it's
just a mirror on the [ __ ] night
reason number one is just a foil piece
before you could even speak you know
someone if if they're attractive
or like they have a good look to them
or like they're they're clean and
they're friendly and you know you could
tell that and you could tell a [ __ ]
disgusting person that doesn't take care
of themselves walking around on the
street with [ __ ] boogers hanging out
their nose you know that's you what the
hell is that the guy from men in black
you don't even need to be a human being
like if you had [ __ ] bunch of lion
lionesses right and you had like a
mufasa [ __ ] all the lionesses
want to [ __ ] him
you know me like that the beauty thing
it's like people do put a lot of it on
society i understand a little bit of
that exists but i think a lot of it also
just is innate in us to try to find the
prime like mate for ourselves right
we're all trying to find a mufasa yeah
dude
[ __ ]
whoever you know mother effing scarface
is always trying to freaking yeah
scarface
smartphones don't get no [ __ ] dude rap
group the rap group bro you never sat
next to somebody on a bus and you're
like
oh
why on a bus
can you say it that loud on the airport
shuttle to the drop-off i don't know i
think because a lot of it is just like
hygiene
like that's you know determines if
you're beautiful or not or like
another one is like
like fitness like if you're physically
fit it's like i want to make kids with
you yeah you know like
so there's like naturally counting them
up what about like like skin like skin's
a big thing you know like like if we
have skin problems like i have eczema
right it's unattractive because it's
like bad genes
it's not because society is like oh you
know they're shining eczema it's like no
everybody looks at it and goes i look at
it and i'm like oh that's this that's
that's disgusting i need to lotion this
[ __ ] you know what if you have a big
nose not me but like
not this beautiful you're trying to
point out your nose is nice
okay your nose is great
i don't know but it to me it's like it's
i don't think it's like that bad where
people are like i'm a vomit if i see
your face like if it's a big nose no
one's gonna vomit you know some people
might yeah
people will like shame you for how you
look normally even if you are healthy
hygienic whatever some people just don't
look good that's true right yeah some
things are just unaesthetically what are
some examples of faces where you would
throw up on oh man
a person who's throwing up probably
because you know why like the guy that
was throwing water at mike tyson that
guy i saw him and i just oh man i just
want to punch him he did have a punch he
has that face he looks like randall from
recess he's always like telling on
everybody he looked like that guy looks
like he sucks you know they say like the
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
right i really believe that because i
think
some things that are considered
traditionally ugly sometimes i think is
adorable or cute or imperfections i feel
like so like a pug right it's like an
ugly cute or like or like a bulldog you
look at their face and it's like man you
[ __ ] deformed fat wrinkly cute
[ __ ] like yeah right yeah that's
true subjective yeah it is it's just
even for people another man's trash is
another man's treasure
so you have this like ugly ugly person
that's like your go-to like your woman
yeah freaking you find her beautiful
everybody's like oh like shallow hell
exactly shallow hell
so i don't think there's like a blanket
at least for me because like they'll be
like instagram models and [ __ ] and
everyone's like oh my god i [ __ ]
throw so hard for it i'm like oh her
like she looks weird like she looks like
a plastic creature you know like
not one wrinkle on that body it looks
manufactured like it is i want organic
not gmo you know like i don't know
what about do you think it's possible
let's say that you were like you spent
like three months with a group of 15
people and this girl who was in there is
conventionally ugly but the other like
13 people all conspired together to
treat her like she was the finest girl
on the planet do you think that would
happen in your mind where you would also
accept that
because you know like if it's decided i
think that happens to uh ugly dudes
actually i think ugly dudes that like
end up becoming more famous or
successful people look at him as like
greater than celebrate that person yeah
that's why a lot of chicks they they
they're almost blind to that and it's
almost about the aura and everything you
know but do you think it happens to
women because that's the thing that's
interesting to me yes it does you ever
see the hot chick with a group of ugly
friends it makes the hot chick even
hotter because of what she's around
[Laughter]
game of perspective what is it called
anchoring or some [ __ ] she's hot she's
hotter in in comparison to the rest of
the people she's with what about some
ugly friends what about you then if you
put her with 10 hot girls you're like
you ain't so hot and you guys like your
whatevs you know
what about the ugly chicken in the hot
girl group
is there a way that she becomes hotter
or she just looks even worse it's like
uh like in i was i've never been there
but in i guess sweden or where did the
vikings come from yeah like the that
area sweden and finland i was told all
the women in sweden are beautiful like
they're all supposed to be very very
like oh norway norway norway very
beautiful and then they also told me
because the vikings raped all the
beautiful women back in the day and so
that produced all this like beautiful
people you object that's my objective i
don't think that's true
not maybe not all of them but there's a
good majority why objective i just
sneezed
objection sneeze
they would go on these raids like around
uk or or england i mean uh or europe and
they would kidnap all the hottest girls
and bring them back and they're like wow
you can keep the ugly ones and then so
that's why england has all the ugly
girls and then norway has all the pretty
ones they kept the pretty lovely i was
told this by an english woman which is
my woman so she told me that yo i
benefited from somebody being really
good looking in a group that we went out
with his name is uh yoshi sadarsso
whoever the editor is it's a little
picture here bro doug
we went out to eat with yoshi after we
all trained and it was like me david a
couple other homies they kept giving us
free [ __ ] they just kept giving us oh
here here's this
just because yoshi was like such a
sweetheart and he's the hottest guy
either of the sudarsos they they have
like yoshi's not fair it's not fair oh
yeah it's a superpower everyone's nice
to you when yoshi's around this was like
yeah
[Laughter]
this is um yoshi and peter's the
brothers okay yeah they look like they
want to [ __ ] each other
they talk about all the time they're
saying
look how hot these guys are all right
dude it's getting hot
are you gonna have a family like that
dude yeah that's not fair
and they're related yeah nice good genes
yeah and they're related and they
probably work out too yeah that hot
privilege is i think the worst imagine
here's a set of ranch and my phone
number and you and [ __ ] yoshi rides a
motorcycle and he takes his helmet
he's like what's up guys and he's always
like just doing stuff with his hair
please pull him over he's like sir yes
this is my helmet yes could you do that
again
put it on take it off right now and run
that by for my partner when he gets here
can i ride behind you too sir
taking you downtown but i'm riding with
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you